[Musique]
la journée nationale des aidants c'est
comme un rassemblement de super héros
sans masque et plein d'humilité
ils sont là juste pour respirer le temps
d'une journée
claude à 66 ans il s'occupe de sa femme
atteinte de la maladie de parkinson
depuis 1989 par une jeune dame on
connaît pas cette fois la ville à moi
d'essayer de travailler en attendant un
nom mais malgré tes pas possible donc
effet que dans le labourd démocratique
au moins faire les dépenses comme high
tech est belle et tout était pas et pas
grand chose parce que et d un vieux
monde et des ânes ou personnages et
aider un malade n'est pas tous les jours
facile parce que vous ne faites rien
votre vie beaucoup de talent et mon cas
autour des tables les aidants se
retrouve un vrai moment qu'ils libèrent
j'étais assistante familiale
après j'ai gardé cette fille
[Musique]
ça te change est important
parce que mon bel
chaque famille à leurs problèmes
c'est parce que le monde est pareil à
toutes les personnes qui s'occupent
c'est pareil donc je pense que ça va me
faire du bien à nous tout ici nous avons
fait le choix depuis longtemps de
privilégier le vivre à domicile lorsque
celui ci bien évidemment est possible et
désiré par la personne agir après le
petit déjeuner qui donne des forces
place aux différents stands et c'est
bien là que le sourire est de retour
c'est vrai que pas le temps j'ai de ma
maman qui était de la maladie alzheimer
et puis j'ai un frère qui est atteint
d'un handicap sa famille quand on est on
est vraiment impliqué c'est la fête au
fil des années l'accompagnement des
aidants ses structures et des étapes
difficiles
sachant qu'il y a autant de
problématiques que de contexte c'est une
obligation aujourd'hui de reconnaître
les dents mais seulement depuis 2016
alors que le département le fait de cuir
2012 donc on a une vraie politique
innovante y est relativement complète
puisqu'elle permet d'offrir un panel
d'offres et de services aux aidants qui
ont besoin vraiment pour continuer à
maintenir à domicile les usagers d'un
soutien fort important et d'un soutien
qu'ils soient plutôt innovant avec 1,8
légèrement un petit peu mais c'est pas
beaucoup mais attention bien que le
reste était en même temps une politique
volontariste et innovante pour le
département chef de file de l'action
sociale car créer du savoir un statut
une compétence reconnue tout en
accompagnant les aidants n'est pas chose
facile
chaque aidant la à la même problématique
donc d'où la difficulté pour le
département justement de faire en sorte
de trouver
on va dire entre guillemets la formule
idéale
chaque aidant à sa problématique et
chaque aidant a besoin d'être aidé quoi
et on essaie au niveau du département de
faire en sorte de de trouver la formule
magique pour que chaque personne y
trouve son compte mais croyez moi ça
n'est pas facile
cette journée reste un moment de
respiration de bonheur pour ces super
héros mais c'est juste une
[Musique]